well finally here at four in many cities
restaurants can only serve customers
outdoors and certainly christian the big
challenge is to keep those customers
warm in the winter months
some establishments finding a new way to
turn up the temperature
eating outdoors under a tent we have
your
mulled wine has customers warming up to
something new on the menu
as we are outside i'm freezing so i'm
often looking for something that's more
and that's why the upscale korean
steakhouse in new york called cote
is serving mulled wine so these are the
two mulled wine cocktails we offer
beverage director victoria james says
the red mulled wine comes warm with a
shot of hard liquor
nuts and raisins the white wine version
includes gin and cinnamon
apple cider is what it kind of reminds
me of the pandemic
completely changed how we interact with
our guests simon kim who owns the
michelin starred restaurant thinks the
drinks could become the next big thing
for the first time in new york city hot
cocktail became more of
a necessity offering mold one is more
than just keeping up with trends
bars and restaurants are adapting their
menus to hang on to business
it's a survival mechanism chris stang
ceo of zaggett restaurant guide says hot
cocktails are part of that survival
you can find spike cider at washington
dc's truckston inn
the sportsman club in chicago has hot
toddies and atlanta's wrecking bar is
serving up
hot buttered rum there's been a lot of
necessary i guess what you would call
innovation in new york that includes
this 19th century flaming whiskey
concoction at dante
and the restaurant niche niche offers a
boozy hot chocolate topped with
chartreuse laced whipped cream
back at cote this is really a hot ticket
here
which has the restaurant developing new
hot cocktails for future menu